so you talked about the need for a
four-day workweek or someone like to say
a three-day weekend yes I I did the math
those works so I was I looked into this
and I think you know this like I was
looking in the history of weekends and
really it started I mean there's been
they've been around for a while but it
really was a union thing right like the
unions demanded like hey we get two days
off like that's the move and it was in
the right after the Great Depression if
I recall yeah yeah it was in the Fair
Labor Standards Act of 1938 40-hour
workweek well first let me let me
explain the thinking behind it where
right now our work week is getting
longer not shorter and it's having a
disastrous set of effects on millions of
people where we have this mental health
crisis that we talked about last week we
have this worship of work work ISM and
we're sleep-deprived I mean you can name
it they're like all these stacked
effects and it's getting worse
now economists like Keynes projected
we'd have a 15 hour work week by now
because we'd be so wealthy and it turns
out he was right about the level of
wealth like it like that line was
correct but he obviously got the number
of hours in the work week very wrong
because it's been getting longer not
shorter here in the US and Barack Obama
actually said to me we should be looking
at a shorter work week because firms
aren't going to employ people in the
same way that they have previously so
let's see what happens if you do
implement three-day weekends four-day
workweek the big thing people say is
like well won't you then just do 20%
less work and that's not really the way
it happens in real life where
organizations actually become more
productive in many cases if you shorten
the workweek and if you think about the
way most of us work we have bursts of
productivity and then bursts of
relative like I'm not really doing a
whole lot right now
and those bursts tend to correspond to
when the deadline is but also what our
schedule is like I'll give you an
example the most productive day that
anyone has is the day before they're
gone they go on vacation for a while
like like that like that day all of a
sudden is like you know this gets so
much stuff done
ok knows that feeling - yeah so is this
just getting done is done today so your
productivity expands or contracts
depending upon the schedule and that's
why if you have a four-day workweek you
may get the exact same amount done as
you wouldn't a five-day workweek just
get it done in less time so let's
stipulate that productivity let's say
stays the same even though studies have
shown I'll actually go up now then then
you have a three-day weekend which ends
up improving your level of rest your
mental health your relationships your
time with family
it actually has even been shown to help
more evenly distribute like domestic
responsibilities so that there are all
of these positive effects and the
negative effects are as far as I can
tell quite absent in the data and here's
the kicker it would help create jobs at
the margins because if you're a firm and
you have a four-day work week and let's
say you need coverage then you might
have to hire another like you know 20%
of people and then like have them work
different periods of time so and right
now we're in a situation where we need
to create jobs in the worst way where
we're gonna be short tens of millions of
jobs for months so anything we can do
that's gonna stimulate hiring is a win
so the the four-day workweek to me is
something that we should be seriously
looking at and the way you make it
happen is the same way you made the two
day Work Week happen which is you pass a
law saying hey guess what like these are
gonna be the expected work hours like of
course you can have a firm that
as people work different hours but then
you have to accommodate your employees
in like you know additional ways and
like it it's you know frankly like the
dumb question is like is it's a law and
so right now we the weekend essentially
structure on the 40-hour workweek you're
not allowed to have a number of workers
and a lot of work more than 40 hours a
week keep it an hourly worker after a
certain level right and so you would
make overtime after 30 hours or whatever
well you know you yeah I mean you could
you could work with the number of hours
you could like there different ways you
could make the the weekend longer I have
a feeling though that it wouldn't take
that much because if you were to pass a
law in this direction a lot of major
companies would adopt it and then it's
gonna be very difficult for some
companies to look up and say like
actually we're gonna ignore that
like when literally their competitor
companies or hiring the same people oh
it's like it and so it's really
interesting if you were an employee like
which company I'm gonna choose you're
gonna choose the one that with the
four-day workweek and so they're gonna
end up with like you know better people
who are gonna have the same level of
productivity and higher containment
levels and better rest you know it's
like one of the signs to me about how
sleep-deprived we are is that when you
have daylight savings time when you lose
an hour of sleep car accidents go up
like literally if like you you have like
one less hour sleep it screws us up
enough where we're actually like you
know like a non-trivial number of us are
gonna like get an accident so it's like
that there's and I'm you know it's fun
to have this conversation right now like
after Memorial Day could because you
know it's like that three-day weekend I
was saying is like it's 50% better than
a two-day weekend comeback it you'll
come back into the office like much more
ready to go you'll be more productive
from front to back
there are many workers obviously that
like ironing this well it's like so some
people I know are looking at being like
well it doesn't apply to me because like
I'm like you know I've got a job that
medicine yeah well it's like I get paid
hourly so like what are you talking
about
so they're there have to be ways that we
make it like a universal basic income
make it so that people are able to work
and not feel like they have to work
themselves to the bone the way that many
many people do right now is there an
argument that economic activity will be
boosted because you have more weekends
like do people spend I don't have you
know these numbers do people spend more
on the weekends I imagine yes when you
have free time that's you're going to
dinner that's when you're going on
vacation that's when you're traveling
this when you're spending more on gas
who knows yeah of course you know of
course we spend more money on
recreational stuff on weekends than when
you're working like you know all you can
do is you lunch at your desk and whatnot
right it's the economy that is
stimulative yep the but I also think
this I think is it clearly pinched a
nerve on Twitter on you when you tweeted
it out so that's why I wanted to explore
it more with you in this and you talked
about this a lot personally in on the
trail like this the why of like it begs
a question why are we working you know
I'm saying and I think you it's obvious
ACK where we're working to maximize GDP
like having your GDP contribution today
if not then [ __ ] you but you've kind of
argued that work is activity that make
society better theoretically and now oh
I love to work don't get me wrong I've
learned that the hard way man does Ronny
Chang thing we're like Asians don't take
off they don't stop for Christmas they
don't stop for Thanksgiving like that's
game man like it's like in all day I
love that you like finish your
presidential run you just kept working
you're insane
but the I are we were joking on our team
Andrews the irony of we're gonna work it
with the irony is we're gonna work a
seven day workweek to fight for a
four-day workweek around the rest of the
country oh yeah that's pretty good
summary man because so so here's the
thing too is like if you have a four-day
work week and you're someone who likes
to work then you know what you're gonna
do you're gonna get tons of work done
during
four days and then those other three
days you're gonna do different types of
work on like yourself your family your
health your relationships your community
like you'll find stuff to do if you want
to work like nothing's gonna keep you
from from working but you'll get the
same amount of work done in less time
yeah I'm a fan I was on the fence at
first I was like never changing stuff
and I think there's a lot of arguments
the Pro column and not a lot of
arguments in the con column but here's
the money shot Andrew do you pick Monday
or Friday my instinct is you pick Friday
because I don't get [ __ ] done on Fridays
I'm kidding but you know I mean another
thing you do is you could just like let
a company choose and then you have some
companies in effect Monday and some
comes in effect Friday if you're like a
certain type of business but generally
speaking you'd want to pick the same day
for most companies so that so that
everyone would have the benefits because
one of the things you realize quickly is
that weekends are best when they're
synchronous if you want someone to be
sad you give them time off when no one
else's time off so so so generally
speaking we would just pick Fridays I
think that would be the win